welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and free guy
is ryan reynolds upcoming action comedy
about a game character becoming aware
and taking over the system something we
have never seen before
[Music]
i'm bad and that's good that will never
be good and that's not bad
i am a master builder damn it
but hey this one's got the naughty boy
charm of ryan reynolds which we
definitely haven't seen in a video game
movie talking stupid
mind damn it nah i know this one's got
taika watiti
aka the fortnite loving korg of the mcu
that kid on the tv just called me a
[ __ ] again and with ryan reynolds
reportedly signing a huge deal with
marvel studios
this deadpool chord crossover could be
the first big screen chapter of marvel
phase four
all we need is for reynolds guy to be
revealed as wade wilson
aka noob master 69 and we are good to
go along with the many gaming easter
eggs promised by cast and crew this
trailer
is hiding legit deadpool clues if you
look closely
and flip your vision into gun mode which
for me means never learned how to
socialize properly in grade school and
now sees things
let's break it all down okay so in this
film ryan reynolds plays
guy or blue shirt guy basically a
nameless bank teller non-playable
character
in the game three city based on games
like fortnite and grand theft auto like
in the first trailer a character does
the orange justice emote dance from
fortnite and guy
respawns in a loop whenever he dies kind
of like groundhog day or the hosts of
westworld but then he meets molotov girl
jody comer the avatar of
millie also played by comer
unrecognizable in that turtleneck
guessing i've come to the end of the
road
[Music]
it was you the whole time millie is a
coder for free city alongside
keys joe keary from stranger things both
work for antoine
taika with tt and it looks like their
kiss sparked some ai
sentience into guy and that's what
breaks the game with guy
now fighting back against the players
who rob his bank and is now kind of a
hero good guy
in a world where everyone wants to be
bad guys actually the dude with his
hands up in the bank robbery
reappears when guy gets hit by cars and
later in the big speech i'm guessing
since the bank heist mission never
officially ended
this fella is glitched with his hands
permanently up and yeah guy getting
ping-ponged by those cars
back-to-back is a nod to brad pitt
getting killed at the top of me joe
black
i love this clip
[Applause]
i guess you could read this as an odd to
brad pitt's hilarious
unceremonious death in deadpool 2.
really free city is filled with visual
easter eggs a hologram bottle with
subtle product placement a gag that's
always fun dating back to the days of
winged world
contractor no i will not bow to any
sponsor
the zipliner with a rocket launcher
kills a dude who lets out a
wilhelm scream and there are wanted
signs
on the walls for kids it looks like a
girl with pigtails i'm wondering if
these could be kids
younger than the age limit sneaking
around the game but one of the places in
the city is
a fake id store so that might be how
these kids are getting around that age
limit now the point of view display
shows guy's stats his main move is
harmless
slap and while he doesn't have much
power he does have lots of
stamina and his weapons include a
paperclip
receipt and a metropass and as he looks
the medpack behind it
is a trash bin filled with orange cups
another example of the game glitching
because this is the coffee cup that
guy gets every day from that coffee shop
and if you look at the group shot later
everyone is drinking this same type of
cup but rather than
been clearing with each loop that bin is
filling and filling and filling with
these cups
but behind guy is a red defense grid
counting
down suggesting that this zone is about
to open up with all kinds of danger and
chaos
there's another shot showing a different
glitch a character in the background
outside the coffee shop
repeatedly smacking into a barrier
surrounding the bins
and speaking of that hologram bottle we
saw earlier
i can totally relate with a guy
sluggishly trying to get through my
morning having no idea what's holding me
back
really what that guy needs to do is a
180 to get some
am sweetness with ryan reynolds for me i
have to start every day with cereal been
doing it since i was a kid but
i am not a kid anymore i'm a grown man
talking about video game movies and
comic book characters
so my cereal shouldn't and cannot have
all that sugar and all the other junk
that's in kids cereal
but thankfully with a magic spoon cereal
i can eat cereal and not feel bad about
it thanks by the way to magic spoon for
sponsoring this video
magic spoon has no sugar it has 11 grams
of protein and is only 110 calories per
serving it's keto friendly gluten-free
grain-free soy-free low-carb gmo free
the best part is how good it tastes
not like healthy cereal but more like
tasty cereal
it comes in four different flavors
there's cocoa fruity frosted blueberry
you can try them all in a variety pack
all the flavors are really great but i
especially like this fruity one it'll
remind you of a certain cereal you
probably grew up with but the great
fruity taste is there the texture's
there but it's
far healthier so you're not gonna crash
and your heart's not gonna crash
click the link below to grab a variety
pack and try it today but be sure to use
the promo code new rockstars at checkout
to get
free shipping or go to magicspoon.com
new rockstars
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product it is backed with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they will refund your
money no questions
asked so click on that link below use
the code new rockstars for free shipping
or go to magicspoon.com
new rockstars okay in millie's home
there's some art on the wall showing
iron giant a little cameo ready player
one couldn't get enough of either
molotov girl leads guy into this bar
now those curved doors are the same ones
visible in the previous trailer
in that bearing lot on the other side of
the tracks that guy tries to follow
molotov girl too
maybe this is a hidden zone that npcs
don't normally access but there is
another bar in the city
joe's tavern that bart sign is visible
from the street it's likely a nod to
moe's tavern from the simpsons a cameo
rick and morty couldn't get enough of
either
but inside that bar with the curved
doors you can see the leaderboard with
tuxedo baby on top and i'm wondering if
tuxedo baby is the
baby blue coat dude with a skull mask
who robs the bank that guy fights back
against and if you look closely you can
see that same dude sitting across the
bar
so blue shirt guy taking out the top
point leader could have been what
screwed up the game
so bad there is an appearance by alex
trebek in jeopardy now check out the
categories one of them
is famous blakes and one of those
answers has to be
blake lively actress and ryan reynolds
wife whom he has jokingly referenced as
deadpool
that is why sisterhood of the traveling
pants is pure
pornography guy fights with a steering
wheel as a weapon deploying the airbag
to take someone down but check this out
i don't think we ever see guy
use a firearm of his own like he does
blow away the bank robber with that
shotgun but that was a robber's own
shotgun it's possible that it was even
fired by accident like guy thinks he's
just sleeping
he's just resting in pieces that man
is dead he's so sleepy and then there
are other shots where guy holds a
handgun but he holds it by the barrel
like he's grossed out by it he does tote
heavier artillery at another frame but
he doesn't appear to be firing it
instead guy seems to be weaponizing
vehicles and vehicle parts like the
steering wheel meanwhile he only ever
carries guns
but maybe to dispose them is that a
glock in your pocket
no what it's two blocks yeah
she uses the guns he doesn't and maybe
it's his
confiscation in disposal of weapons like
this in the game
that is pissing off all the other
players so much and it looks as though
free city breaks so badly that antoine
and the devs pull the plug on it
with wide shots of the city collapsing
disintegrating if you look closely there
is a
bridge leading out to the sea on the
other side of a pit formed where the
beach was with all the shots of guy
on that beach i'm thinking his target in
the scene might be to access that bridge
to try to escape
similar if you think about it to truman
in the truman show trying to escape his
simulated reality by heading out
to sea and then one final point i want
to talk about the music it starts with
mariah carey's fantasy and then it
shifts to the who's baba o'reilly a
track so
overused in movies and tv shows that
just a little over a year ago
netflix used dipper joe kerry's other
nostalgia pouring title
stranger things its third season trailer
and yeah bob o'reilly is one of the
songs that people are like this teenage
wasteland song
slaps they think they've discovered this
new obscure cathartic game changer you
gotta hear this song
hear more of this song look with cinemas
shutting down for now
i'm not sure if free guy will be able to
stick to its scheduled december 11th
release date but i do have to say as
a 20th century release owned by the walt
disney corporation
it is legally possible for this movie to
end with a post-credit stinger
revealing guy as a fortnight skin of
new master 69 ryan reynolds deadpool
calling it now
comment down below with your favorite
detail from this trailer and join me
to discuss deadpool's future in the mcu
on new rockstar's official discord
server by becoming a patreon at
patreon.comrockstars
subscribe to new rockstars hit that
notification bell follow me on instagram
at eavos following the rockstars thank
you for watching and guys have you heard
of this
song called hallelujah shrek sang it and
it is awesome
[Music]
you